Speaker 1: I went back and forth about
whether to cover this next story,
and I decided to ultimately. And there's
a few points I want to make because there
are kind of some bad takes coming from this
story. So the story that has surfaced is,
Hey, Trump's finances are collapsing. But what's
the evidence? Well, Forbes has this rich list of
the richest 400 Americans that they publish. And
Donald Trump is off the list for the first time
in a really, really, really long time. So Donald
Trump's financial situation is suffering. The
article on Forbes says Donald Trump is worth
an estimated two point five billion dollars,
leaving him $400 million short of the cutoff to
make this year's Forbes 400 list of America's
richest people. The real estate mogul
is just as wealthy as he was a year ago,
when he was number 339 on the ranking, but is down
600 million since the start of the pandemic. Tech
stocks, cryptos and other assets have thrived
in the COVID era, but big city properties making
up the bulk of Trump's fortune have languished,
knocking the former president out of the nation's
most exclusive club. They have this chart showing
Trump's ranking. In terms of wealth, and there was
a point in the late 90s, rather where Trump
was like roughly in the top 100 wealthiest,
then in the early 2000s, he kind of got up
close to the 50th wealthiest and then it's been
declining since 2015. So there's a few different
things here that I think are important because
there's there's some confusion about sort of what
this means. We have to balance. On the one hand,
it really shouldn't be insanely profitable to be
president now. Every president is going to get at
this point, they're going to get a nice book deal
at minimum, for sure. But remember that Donald
Trump still made $1.6 billion over the four years
that he was president now, he said he was going to
be out of his businesses. Blind trust, even though
he didn't really understand what that is, the big
presentation with a stack of paper that was legal
paper that we don't even know what what it did.
He made a killing during his presidency so that
his children, Trump, still made 1.6 billion during
his four years. At the same time, the presidency
did some damage to Trump's brand. I mean,
there's probably close to half the country on
principle wouldn't go to a Trump hotel at this
point in time. And so Trump still filthy rich.
He's just not quite as rich relative to this group
of the richest Americans. Remember, he's still as
wealthy as he was a year ago in terms of dollars.
But because Trump is real estate heavy and a lot
of these other rich people are more diversified,
crypto stocks are the things Trump
in ranking has fallen behind. So
you a lot of people are wanting to take just
like a black and white view. Oh, so well,
if he's no longer in the richest 400, clearly he
didn't rape and pillage for his personal wealth
while he was president. Well, though he benefited
greatly from being president, foreign dignitaries
coming and staying at his hotels in order to
ingratiate themselves with them, et cetera. He
still made 1.6 billion during his presidency.
His kids made a ton of money despite being sort
of loosely or less loosely associated with the
administration. I don't need the guy to be poor,
but let's not allow him importantly to skirt
responsibility and the due process of others
because he's rich when it comes to saying No,
this person, I don't have to testify in this case,
and I don't have to provide documents in that
case and all this other stuff because he used to
be president or B or because he was president at
the time. And the issue of exactly how rich he is
relative to others is less important. So to
some degree, many of Trump's businesses are
struggling. Trump makes a ton of money from other
things as well licensing and different things.
A lot of his hotels aren't doing so well. The
value, property values some have suffered,
there's no doubt about that. But the right is
pointing and saying you guys on the left were
saying Trump was taking advantage of his position
to make money, and he didn't really make money.
No, he did. He still made 1.6 billion. It's just
relative to the other 400 richest Americans.
He comparatively fell slightly behind 400 million
a year. While President is your full time job is
still very, very solid now. The other question
is, has he been honest about his wealth all along?
Did he ever really have? I think at one point he
was claiming three or four billion? Who the hell
knows? That's another question altogether. He's
not an honest guy that we know, but let's not read
more into this than what we actually should, which
is Trump did extremely well while being president,
even though he said it was bad for him financially
to be president. One point six billion is pretty
good. But some other even richer, mostly men,
but people did even better than Trump. That's
fundamentally what it comes down to. We don't
really need to read too much more into it.